come visit tropical yara an island
filled with beautiful flora
stunning vistas friendly locals and of
course
interesting wildlife in this slice of
far cry 6 gameplay we get to see a
little of what we can expect when the
game releases
later in 2021 highlights of course being
good wee pals
of the scaley and fury variety for more
of far cry 6 make sure to like the video
and subscribe to gamespot
oh
good croc
get back here
oh my god what the [ __ ] who are they
protesters artists journalists why we
have to live
your name is paz you're pass you're not
bitcho
you're not a bug you're pass and i need
you here with us man
hmm
that's why you died now i'm going to
call this in
you are going to be slowly
huh
hey
oh
hey yeah
if a dog refuses to break
then we must put them down
the difference between a true yarn and a
fake yarn
it can be hard to see but it's there
a true iron understands that loyalty
to country is key to his survival
good dog good dog
good boy
good though good though
you're an orphan see funny how friends
can be closer than family
remember danny castillo has kept you
an orphan
why do you want to run i watch castillo
order a whole boat of our people shot to
death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath all of you
when tyranny is law revolution is
ordered
gonna save yara with library cards i
have a list
oh
um
good night
ah
[Music]
cool
uh
[Music]
hello hey
come on
you